don't live in the past
change changes because that's the nature
of life and if you don't go with it you
may look like really you might be dead
I know people who live in the past they
just live all the time talking about
someone habits than 30 years ago they're
not zombies and I can hang out with
those people I know but I can't spend
more than five minutes over because I
feel like suicide at the end of it
because I feel so good about being happy
but they're so visible because it's a
your life is in session for many years I
thought life is a big rehearsal for the
big event and somebody in the center
said Tony this is the big event right
facin session
you know we spend so much time thinking
it's a rehearsal for peeping event the
big red carpets in the sky that is not
so this is an interesting one for me
first I think too many people live in
the past I think too many people are
living off of their past glory or are
living through other people right like
they didn't have a lot of successes
they're living through their kids and
the only value they get is when their
kids go off and do something I think
that is just fundamentally broken yes
you love your kids yes you love the
people around you but it's your life you
got to do the thing that you want to go
out and do and stop just telling stories
of what happened before stop reliving
what happened five 10 20 years ago and
now is the time to go up and do
something amazing this may seem really
bad but I was reading a book this
morning
and one of the exercises in it was
around rewiring your brain and so the
concept here is whether whether you're
feeling down and whether you're feeling
happy
you can rewire your brain to feel the
opposite if you want to so if you're
feeling down you can take that negative
thought you have and you picture it and
you see it as this big overwhelming huge
thing in your life and then you mentally
look at it and it's getting smaller and
further off in distance and smaller and
smaller and smaller and smaller and
smaller until it kind of fades off into
the Sun you wake up you open your eyes
you feel happier you can do it the other
way to feel happier by looking at
positive things take one really positive
memory that you have and just make it
big make it bigger in your life and
brighter and more in-your-face and feel
the happiness that comes from it and
it's so it's an interesting exercise to
test and when I first read about it I
had a hard time thinking about one
defining happy moment which sounds
really sad but it wasn't sad for me
because I don't live in the past I don't
remember how old I am you know I want to
get asked in those forms how old are you
I have to think about what year is it
when was I born and make the calculation
when people ask me when did I start my
youtube channel how long have I been in
the youtube world I don't know who cares
like I don't care when I started I can't
what I'm doing right now I care what
where we're going I care about the
impact that I wanna have not what I did
years ago I don't I legitimately don't
remember unless it's part of the story
the narrative of like lessons that I've
learned that I don't want to forget or
there could be teachable moments for you
guys I don't remember that stuff all the
milestones that we hit I don't know when
did we hit a hundred thousand I have no
idea how long did it take me to get a
thousand ten thousand a hundred thousand
even now half a mile I don't know how
long it took who cares why is that why
does that matter how is that relevant I
want to be happy with what I'm doing
right now and make something great going
forward and so I had trouble thinking of
one defining moment of happiness there's
like the one happy moment in my life
because I want today to be happy I want
today to be the happiest day I want
tomorrow to be the happiest day and
maybe I'm just a weird bird that way
because I know a lot of people that's
what they live off of it's like it took
me this long to get here and
no they remember all the dates and all
the milestones I don't know let's turn
that into the question of the day am I
the weird bird or do you guys feel the
same way are you living in the past do
you remember every detail every moment
and you're not happy now are you focused
on being happy with what you're doing
today and going forward I'm going to be
fine the creative way to embrace the
genius at the end and do both let me
know what you think are you living in
the past or not leave it in the comments
below super curious to find out I also
want to give a quick shout out to Tim
Murphy from clever restaurant consulting
comm Tim thank you so much for picking a
cup of my book your one word it really
means a lot to me man I appreciate it
thank you guys again for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is much loved and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
events presser hey believe nation for
those of you who want a little bit more
context and value around not living in
the past here are a few more bonus clips
that I think you'll enjoy most people
have good great goals I want to increase
my income and lose weight and get out of
debt and be thin and happy and healthy
and have a wonderful family but then
then they decide but before I start I'm
going to take a vacation to a beautiful
place called someday Isle and in my
estimation 80% of the population lives
on some day I'll some day I'll lose some
weight and some day I'll read that book
and listen to that program and join the
nest yes network and there's some day
I'll get out of death someday I'll
increase my income but it's always
someday I'll if you want to be a great
success there's one simple rule is vote
yourself off the island for life if you
decide you're going to do something do
it you know what they've done dozens and
dozens of studies over the years they
find that there's one major difference
between successful people and
unsuccessful people as successful people
launch they start they get on with it
they just do it unsuccessful people get
the same ideas in the same information
but they've always got an excuse for not
starting so many people in life we all
know these guys right they peaked at
high school they were prom king they
were
quarterback of the team and they go
through life and you see them ten years
later and they're there sit at the bar
on a Tuesday with the male pattern
baldness and they're like bro back in
the day I was the [ __ ] man and they
can't pay their bills or driving a
hooker and they've turned into a
basically a complete accelerated version
of themselves which is a douche bag and
they haven't done anything with their
lives right and we see these people all
the time and the reason these people
don't progress is because they they
focus on the glory days they focus on
the things they have achieved in the
past and they don't let themselves work
towards a better future and guys you
have to be able to look at yourself and
be honest with yourself on this if this
is you you have to stop this behavior
okay when you focus on what you did last
year or what you did two years ago or
what you did last month or the award I
wanted the company function or the the
sales numbers that I hit and beat
everybody on this on the squad or
whatever when you focus on this guys
that is energy that you could be putting
into actually improving and focusing on
the task at hand which is today okay
champions don't soak in you know Kobe
Bryant doesn't sit there and talk about
how many MVPs he's won or how many
championships he's won know the
[ __ ] up at 3 o'clock in the
morning practicing every day why do you
think he is so great he's not great
because he's great he's great because he
puts the [ __ ] work in on a daily
basis and he wins every game day our
past is very determinant when you think
about Europe or the Western Hemisphere
in general we are stuck by issues of the
past it is the past that holds back you
know and if you said that you were as
I've done in the past you said let me
burn everything let me get rid of
everything in the past you you're free
to start thinking about the future but
if you're still collecting the past and
looking to the Past as a solution
having history is a very strong anchor
you're unable to move forward because
there are historical reasons why our
tribe of humanity is such a slow changer
because change is very very scary and
human beings or do scary things on their
own they take something much bigger to
force them into change for every human
being individual it's the heart attack
the car accident the something that
happened which was much bigger than you
which suddenly you wake up and say oh my
god I've been spending all my life
inside a box just working for someone
else oh isn't there a better way for
Humanity in general it is this that
suddenly it stops raining suddenly
everything goes crazy and you can't
control the climate so that's big enough
if the world were hit by a meteorite it
would be enough it takes enormous things
like that so we are a bit didn't
dinosaurs in that sense that we will
roam around and do our thing until we're
hit by something much bigger than us and
that's true even for the individual who
needs a heart attack to wake up to find
out that they've been working too much